I will be staying away from spoilers in this
video, so if you haven’t read the book or
seen the 1989 version of the film, you’re
still safe here.
I will discuss the lore and explain a few
minor details of the plot that happen early
on.
If you want to know the meaning of this spiral
on the tree, then stick around to the end
of this video.
This video is sponsored by Wondershare Filmora,
it’s a great option if you’re looking
to get into editing videos and you’re just a
beginner.
You can just drag your videos right into the
timeline, and the program comes with music,
transitions and filters and effects.
You can also get more assets from the Filmora
Effects Store, like the new Creepy Halloween
Pack.
I’ll be using those effects in this video,
so if you’re interested, be sure to visit
the link in the description.
It looks like 2019 is going to be an awesome
year for Stephen King fans with Pet Sematary
and IT: Chapter 2 on the way; and if you followed
my channel in 2017, you’ll know IT was one
of the first big Things You Missed episodes to
get super popular.
So today we’ll be taking a drive down the
road from Derry, Maine to Ludlow, Maine to
take a look at all the Things You Missed in
the new trailer for Pet Sematary.
Roll it.
“So many trees.”
“It’s beautiful right?”
“It’s definitely not Boston.”
That’s right, it looks like the Creed family
moves to Maine from Boston in this movie,
as opposed to Chicago, where they’re from
in the book.
Chicago is also where the parents of the wife,
Rachel Creed, live.
There’s further evidence in the family’s
Massachusetts license plate, and Louis’s
Cape Cop shirt, which also has the year 2016
printed on it, signaling that the 2019 version
will be at, or near present day, just like
IT: Chapter 2 which will be set in 2016.
The time period may also hold a clue as to
why the family is now from Boston instead
of Chicago.
In the book, which takes place in the 80s,
there’s a scene where Rachel needs to quickly
get back home while visiting her parents in
Chicago.
She ends up booking a series of connecting
flights, and there’s even a scene in the
1989 movie where she runs through the terminal
to board a flight that has already closed
its doors.
In a post-9/11 setting however, none of that
is as realistic, so the family may be located
out of Boston so that Maine is just a drive
away, rather than a flight away.
Boston’s Logan International Airport is
the closest airport to Maine that Rachel
is able to get to in the book, and she ends
up driving from there to her home, so making
the family from Boston in this movie just
simplifies that journey.
Hear that cry in the background?
That’s the cry of the Wendigo, a mythological
cryptid said to be located in the Northeastern
United States.
The Wendigo is one of the better known Native
American legends, said to be a human cannibal
transformed over time into a giant bipedal
deerlike creature that eats human flesh.
In Pet Sematary the book, the Wendigo cursed
the Micmac tribe burial ground in Ludlow,
granting it the power to bring those who are
buried their back to life as undead cannibals.
We don’t actually get to see the Wendigo
in the 1989 movie, but there may be a clue
in the 2019 trailer that it will make an appearance
this time -- I’ll get back to that later
on in this video.
So the drums played by the animal mask children
represent the tribal music of the Micmac tribe,
and the cry heard in the distance could be
the Wendigo.
Speaking of the kids in the animal masks,
what’s the deal with them?
As far as I can remember, there are no such
kids in the book, so who are they?
In the book, there are a couple of old stories
told by the Dr. Creed’s neighbor, Jud Crandall.
When he first shows them the Pet Sematary,
he explains that it was created by kids who
had lost their pets to trucks on the dangerous
road the town is situated on.
My guess is that this is just a flashback
scene showing the kids burial ritual for their
pets.
The trailer is cut to make it look like Rachel
and Ellie actually see the kids’ funeral
procession, but I don’t think the actual
movie will be cut like that; just speculating
here, but I think they’re just using clips
out of context.
We also get to see the family’s cat, Church,
who doesn’t look as creepy as the cat in
the 1989 version, but bears a much stronger resemblance
to his appearance on the cover of the book.
There is a pretty creepy moment from the cat
though and we’ll talk about it later in
this video.
As I mentioned, the road outside of the house
is extremely menacing.
This shot of a truck blazing though seems
to be an exact replica of a shot used in the
1989 movie.
However, there is one noticeable difference.
The license plate of this truck reads C61
-- the alphanumeric translation of which says
CGI.
Maybe this is a small hint that this 2019
film will take advantage of computer generated
imagery to do things that the 1989 version
wasn’t able to, like show a realistic rendering
of the Wendigo, or show a more graphic depiction
of “the scene”.
(Those of you familiar with the story know
the one I’m talking about.)
But, for all I know, maybe this is just a
set of random letters and numbers, let me know
what you think in the comments.
The next thing I’d like to point out is
the scene here of Louis getting out of bed
and discovering that his feet are covered
in dirt.
In the book, this takes place right after
he has this dream, where the ghost of one
of his former patients, most likely this guy,
brings him to the Pet Sematary and warns him
never to cross this barrier, known as the
Deadwood, the divide between the Pet Sematary
and the cursed burial ground.
He wakes up at first relieved that it was
just a dream, until his daughter notices the
smell and he discovers his feet are covered
in dirt.
Louis’s deceased patient, Victor Pascow,
makes several appearances to Rachel in the
80s movie adaptation, and that looks to also
be the case in 2019.
Remember when I first talked about the first
trailer for IT, and pointed out that Pennywise’s
eyes were, at the time, missing from the reflection
in the water?
"If you look closely at Pennywise's reflection
right here, you'll notice that it's eyes don't
seem to reflect in the water.
Which is pretty creepy if you ask me."
Yeah.
Get a load of this.
Hopefully they don’t end up replacing the
eyes for the final movie, like they did for
IT, unless it ends up being even creepier
than the dark void.
One thing that was absent from the 1989 movie
adaptation is a character named Norma Crandall,
Jud’s old arthritic wife who, in the book,
without spoiling anything, is a central part
in setting the main events in motion.
She’s replaced by this caretaker character
named Missy Dandridge in the 80s movie, but
this quick shot in the trailer could possibly
mean that she’ll have an appearance in the
upcoming film.
Side note -- the reason that I keep referring
to it as “an upcoming movie” is because
I always get these comments on my movie trailer
Things You Missed episodes that say, “this
is so stupid, analysing the trailer, why don’t
you just watch the movie?”
Which I do almost always put out a longer
Things You Missed for the movie as soon as
it’s out, but for whatever reason, there’s
always that person who ignores that episode
and comes to complain about the trailer analysis.
So to those people watching after April 2019:
why don’t you just watch the episode that
I did on the movie?
The last thing I’d like to talk about though
from the trailer, is this image of the tree
with the spiral on it.
This is another symbol that I don’t remember
being in the first movie, but it definitely
is in the book.
Louis draws this shape in the dirt at one
of the graves with his finger without even
realizing he is doing so.
Then, upon returning to the Micmac burial
ground, he realizes the entire thing is shaped
like a spiral and wonders if anyone had ever
seen this land from above.
So the spiral is a symbol of the power that
this cursed land has over the town and its
inhabitants.
Continuing on with the analogy to IT, just
as Derry seems to have an overlooked history
of bad things happening to it that is driven
by the malevolence of Pennywise; Ludlow has
a similar force presiding over it driven by
the power of the Wendigo.
In other words, the spiral is to Pet Sematary
what the red balloon is to IT.
If you’re looking forward to seeing Pet
Sematary, then leave a like on this video.
Some of you may recall that the 89’ film
ended with an original song by The Ramones.
"I don't want to be buried.
In a Pet Sematary."
I highly doubt that there would be another
song tie-in today, but if there was, what
modern punk band do you think would perform
it?
I imagine it would probably be Fall Out Boy
or something, although there is a certain
other band rumored to be returning in 2019…
Let me know your thoughts in the comments.
I’ll be covering a bunch of topics related
to the new adaptations of Pet Sematary and
IT, so if you love Stephen King novels then
remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.